ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show at his Memorial Day weekend
the kickoff to summer and what a wild
and wet summer it's gonna be it's gonna
be partying boozing it up at the beach
buds and suds real fun splishing and
splashing what a joyous time we're gonna
have this summer I mean could anything
be more fun masks and gloves and spikes
and wave runners jet skis beach balls
and corona balls and just you know make
of it what you will the funds there if
you find it the fun is there if you find
it ventilators and fireworks
what is summer beaches are opening up I
guess they have a drones drones will fly
over the beaches tell you to social
distance in the water
that'll be nice Bonin won't that be nice
you're on the beach and a drone goes
please keep six feet I've just ends be
nice just she'll be like is that a
jellyfish you'll see it's just a drone
she just drones in the water swimming
around is that a shark no it's a robotic
it's a robotic reminder to stay six feet
away from another human being isn't that
nice
what a fun summer it's gonna be I'm
trying to do I'm on these some of these
dating apps man the nightmare the hell
of some of these dating apps people are
just really first of all the humor on
dating apps like the cute-cutesy humor
like the great thing about people that
are really hot is that they never have
to communicate effectively that's such
an important part of really hot people's
relationships is because they're
commuting their communications all
physical so when you see really hot
people talk to each other they just
giggle because they're just want to [ __ ]
each other the whole time and they're
just thinking about how much they want
to [ __ ] the other person and then
they're just like laughing at that
they're like giggling like oh oh that
breads good I wanted to be your dick but
other people have to like actually
to relate to other people and it's
nightmarish like they're on these dating
I'm saying one guy goes if you don't
like Disney like we'll get along if you
like Disney it's like you of it you have
a Disney ultimatum like what is wrong
with you you have a Disney deal-breaker
just two dumb jokes and also the [ __ ]
Trump shirts and the like that's your
life that you don't like Trump that's
your whole that's what you you that's
what you're selling that you you you
don't like Trump there's nothing else
except that how sad how deeply tragic
your life must be and all these dating
have questions are like if there was a
movie about your life what would it be
it's like these stupid dumb meaningless
you know cutesy fun questions you're
supposed to have like cute banter you're
supposed to like comment on people's
questions and everything like that it's
so worthless you know like you look at
these my favorite thing to do alone is
listen to vibey music and chill this is
these are real people fact about me that
surprises people I speak Spanish
fluently I mean what I wanted to write
like fact about me that surprises
someone I killed a woman something like
that
that's real humor not some goofy [ __ ]
that's something like actually funny my
love language is acts of service
I mean how sick
are these people my personal brand is
dark humor as a defense coping mechanism
that's somebody and I guarantee they
have a horrible sense of humor it's just
so bad out there man I'm not saying I'm
some prize but I'm able to come up with
better answers than this what I order
for the table every time somebody goes
mozzarella sticks every time where are
you where are you eating you trash bag
okay guys always think to the star of
their own movie so they love things like
this they're they're they're incapable
of realizing that there are other people
out there and that they are not
interesting they're not stars they're
not the whole show does not need to be
centered around them but it's not
possible for many of them because many
of them were told they were very special
their whole entire life people told me I
was special but they were right see the
difference they were correct but a lot
of other people were getting bad
information fake news the summer is here
and the beaches are opening and it's
going to be very fun to see how this
plays out I don't know anything about
virus transmissions so we shall see CDC
was like by the way doesn't really live
on surfaces our bad thought I lived on
surfaces you know how you were wiping
down your groceries for the last three
months
frantically scrubbing every surface you
came in contact with well we were wrong
about that sorry we figured we would
earn on the side of caution and just
tell you that this thing's trying to
kill you on every way on inanimate
objects out of the mouths of people we
just figured that the default was to
have you terrified of everything not
only people but desks elevator buttons
anything no I'm sure it is possible
transmission but they say that
transmission is actually rather unlikely
the great Ray Cup will be coming up in
the broadcast later on he is not dead
that was a rumor floating around ray
Kumpf is alive and wild as ever and when
he comes on the show today he
drop some I mean things we should
probably edit out he's completely he's
just he's an untamed man you know he is
just I believe I asked him how he was
doing with the quarantine one time and
he said I'm no longer in the dark room I
have a sense of time that was his answer
I am no longer in a dark room I have a
sense of time so just to give you an
idea of what you're dealing with there
with the great rate comp when he joins
us as well thank you everybody for
retweeting you know or sharing on
instagram the corona ball video that we
made where I wore a corona ball costume
and went around Los Angeles I did not
think my career was going to be this but
it is we live in a you know life is an
unending series of nightmares and that
is I got rid of my manager who I'd been
with for three years good guy but we
just had to part ways I wanted a real
Hollywood manager I've signed with
somebody by the name of gist Lane
Maxwell and she is going to be
representing me we'll put her info on
the website if anybody wants to contact
her we haven't had a face-to-face
meeting yet but she seems very excited
about the brand she wants to meet me in
a canyon by Malibu late at night so who
knows she told me to come alone without
a cell phone
weird these Hollywood managers are weird
you know Melinda Gates is gonna drive me
Melinda Gates that she'll drive me to
this meeting with my new Hollywood
manager you know it'll be awkward if I'm
at Bill & Melinda you know yeah I was
like hey what's up Bill Gates is like
did you do a video where you implied
that I had sex with a bat and gave birth
to coronavirus and I'd have to go yes I
did because you didn't not do that bill
you know but go smash that retweet
button that's what youtubers talk to
like yeah what's up it's your boy it's
your boy Tim Dylan YouTube yo what's up
YouTube it's your boy tiptoe
like button smash every trip today we're
filling my kiddie pool with Cheerios I
don't know why we're doing it but we're
doing it and it's got 90 million views
because we live in a fallen world where
people have no families and they roll on
opiates so they just want to put makeup
on their face and watch me swim around
in Cheerios cuz life's a hell anyway
death to anyone that had any Talent like
and subscribe
smash that retweet button today I'm
driving a Lamborghini up a hill don't
know why but you're gonna [ __ ] watch
it love it and share it don't you wish
you had a Lamborghini you've got nothing
inside of you don't even look don't even
look for anything to put inside of you
just like and subscribe smash it baby
it's what YouTube's all about you know
YouTube's all about it said what if we
ate chicken fingers in a hot-air balloon
that's like what YouTube content is
they're like like and subscribe you know
we're spend a lot of money on this video
but I don't care because I want to make
you guys happy I want to make you guys
happy that's why for this video we're
giving my grandma over 19 that's right
it's just like six kids going just grab
it an old woman go just coughing down
the truck we're switching my
grandmother's venture ventilator out
with an accordion like it subscribe
smash that retweet button I literally
never felt I have no conscience I'm
perfectly suited to succeed in this
country liked it subscribe smash to
retweet button my best friend died in
front of me and I didn't blink
smash that retweet button like and
subscribe I'm 46 and I dressed like a 12
year old liked it subscribe I'm in my
mid-40s my fanbase is nine like it
subscribe I mean so we're just trying to
succeed in new mediums that's what we're
trying to do we're trying to go into new
mediums it's I'm not perfect I get it
you know I'm just you know
I'm just trying to branch out into the
into the new world we're trying to make
funny things that's all so go like and
subscribe so go subscribe to the Tim
Dillon show on YouTube if all of you did
that that would be great but many of you
don't do that and I don't know why cuz
you think you better cuz you're
listening to this while you jog around
and you know go subscribe ok support
YouTube's not helping us Instagram is
not gonna help us none of these tech
giant's are going to help us because
were you know a little edgy little
unpredictable were funny it's just funny
mark Normand at a great point cuz edgy
just used to mean funny like he would go
to meetings and they'd be okay that
that's this thing you're doing is edgy
like that's good right maybe like we're
nervous but like it just meant funny so
all we are here is funny so go and
support us we appreciate how much you
guys support the patreon we love that
that's great our patron episodes are
good but also in the larger scheme of
things we also need to make sure that
you guys are out there and you know
wearing the merch sharing the episodes
literally being devoted to me in a way
that's unhealthy scaring people losing
friends over how much you bring up the
videos stalking me trying to kill me
forcing me to live somewhere else deep
in the Hollywood Hills with security
afraid to leave my house coming up to me
and grocery store screaming when you see
me falling down on the street crying
making it uncomfortable threatening to
kill yourself killing yourself coming
back to life cuz it didn't work telling
me that I'm the reason that you came
back to life you met me in the afterlife
and I am God that's the YouTube fame
that's the type of Fame that those
[ __ ] having that's a Fame that
I deserve I deserve a fanbase of emo
Psychopaths on the edge of a mass
shooting or killing themselves but
instead they decide to consume my
content I deserve Instagram dm's and
Twitter DMS from people telling me that
I'm the only thing that stands between
them and putting a gun in their mouth
that's what I deserve that's the kind of
fanbase I deserve not these [ __ ]
lackluster thirty year olds it may see
me at Zanies and may not
I mean a hardcore group of sick fox that
need help
cutters people that are afraid to leave
their home the only reason they do it is
on the off chance that they'll bump into
me in a Barking Lot and it'll be like
Moses in the burning bush and they fall
and start screaming think they dropped
their phone cuz they're shaking they go
into some parkinson's-like frenzy
whenever they see me and people that
even look like me fat people and
lesbians anybody that looks like me they
do a double-take in their pulse quickens
and their heart goes up that's the kind
of fan base I deserve I'm sick of these
comedy fan lackluster maybe we'll see
him when he comes into Tulsa maybe he
won't
I want a digital fanbase of psychopaths
kids that are sent home from school
because they're good they're there there
they might sell farm and I want the only
thing to be in their phone is a picture
of me and they've carved an axe into my
face because I am a god to them I am a
deity that's online same and I want it
just by the shirt that's what I'm saying
by the life in the big city shirt you
see these youtubers that go to malls
people go crazy they start screaming for
them these tick tock errs why am I not
in the hype house or the sway house I
think sway house is better as well
why am I why can't I be big Cuddy
there's a little honey I should be big
honey little huh tea is a tick tock er
who's got three trillion followers and
he's he weighs 19 pounds and he's just
like he looks like rider strong the kid
was in Boy Meets World and his name is
chase hugs it's like could there be a
more tick tocking name than chase hood
it's like my name is chases my name is
Madison chase I'm rich and you're not
you know my name is is this is Gucci
Lamborghini you know it's like and and
this this kid is just a massive massive
success and I don't forget anyone their
success he's successful because like
till they do a rap song and they sing to
it and they try to avoid the N word
they're like oh my
not gonna mouth that one dance by the
pool they just dance by the pool that's
what it is just dance by the pool you
know and God loved them but that's what
I want to do I want to be invited to one
of these homes and I want to begin to
make content with these people I think I
have a lot to add I think I have a lot
why let's make a dance about imperialism
let's do it
let's make a dance about the CIA killing
michael hastings in front of the tree
let's do it a tic toc like look here
goes the car we drive the car
kennedy would do the kennedy dance like
why not involve some element of
conspiracy thinking in the dance why not
do a great depression dance well we all
were all in line and like the food bank
people are coughing Sidda have any
health insurance I'm just saying I can
go to different media I'm trying to
expand the mediums I don't want to just
sit here in yelling no microphone while
I just gets the cab dispatcher fat
because that's no reason to not can't
dispatchers in Long Island like 7,000
pounds of the guys whose arm does anyone
like a Bobby dukka dukka head go to to
car you just picked that guy up on Ocean
Avenue to car to car you pick up up on
ocean yes so call we just got them we
put them up on Ocean all right you'd be
swell gonna sit here all right I ride
all right you got to go down and
McDonald Street got a two-car go to
McDonald's Street I'm 600 pounds I
smoked a cigarette
go to McDonald Street dukka dukka they
never left it was always a small little
room in a train station they never left
it was like a little hot and they fit
just in the hot nerd fat was like it was
like literally pouring out of the
windows and they just like the only
movement they did was they would move
their hand to their mouth with the
cigarette that was in the old days when
you used to take cabs to do cocaine to
get cocaine and do it you know not
everybody could do cocaine in the
Hollywood Hills
people have to do it in Long Island in a
cab we used to be able to smoke
cigarettes and cabs it worked they were
great times in this country is what I'm
saying you don't know what freedom was
freedom was stealing money from your
family and being able to smoke a
cigarette in a cab on the way to get
cocaine with a pregnant woman named
Michelle the great Raymond comp will
come up is coming up here this episode
of the Tim Dylan show is sponsored by
blue Chu guys remember the days when you
were always ready to go it's summer it's
time to [ __ ] blue troop brings you the
first chewable with the same
fda-approved active ingredients as
viagra cialis blue she was prescribed
online by licensed physicians you don't
have to go to the doctor officer wait in
line at the pharmacy and it shifts right
to your door in a discreet package blue
to works is to belitz quick if you need
to [ __ ] and you want to [ __ ] it's time
to [ __ ] it's the summer summer is just
hot sweaty sex and you're not gonna be
ready if you have a soft knish like
penis you need to have a hard dick and
you need to get it by chewing the blue
baby blue2 dot-com promo code Tim to try
it free okay they're trying it free you
have nothing to lose
literally nothing to lose this isn't
like getting married or having children
where it can go wrong this is like no
investment on your part no expenditure
of any [ __ ] money think of how many
things you do in your life getting a new
job even making a new friend
buying a house so many things you make
an investment of time and emotion you
don't have to do any of that here it's a
simple click of the mouse and they send
it to your home discreet packaging so
when your mother who you live with finds
it because the bar that you worked at
close she could just hand it to you and
think maybe it's something reputable
that someone is sending you because
you're a high you know you're you're in
good standing and you're a member of the
community she doesn't know it's chewable
dick pills you don't even have a sexual
partner you just want you to take to get
hard you want to wake up look at it and
go back to
but the point is you need confidence
blue troop gives you that confidence
blue true allows you to walk in any
situation consensual and have your penis
nice and hard and ready to do the job
ready to hammer that [ __ ] that ass all
that mouth that [ __ ] that ass all that
mouth that's what that's what a Broadway
show is gonna be soon my neck my back my
[ __ ] and my cry
that's a Broadway show they'll be soon
he put like it used to be like really
cutesy like Oklahoma where they were
like I reckon if I see a feller I will
land soon it's gonna be I put his [ __ ]
in my mouth right down to the bowls then
I let him finish in my throat I open my
ass cheeks on the second date I knew
that he was a special DJ or whatever so
blue2 dot-com promo code t IM the tried
free you have nothing to lose except
being an in cell did you know two or
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 think about that two out of
three the best way to prevent hair loss
is to do something about it while you
still have hair left get treated from
home you used to have to go to the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription now thanks to keeps you can
visit a doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered right to your arm
this is one of my big fears going bald I
mean this is a huge fear of mine some
people do it and they can make they can
make it work but so many people can so
this is literally something that if
you're having this problem or if before
you have this problem you know one of my
old bosses used to tell me change before
you have to great quote they make it
easy and deliver the medication every
three months so that you can say goodbye
to pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits keeps overs generic
versions of only two of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there so you may have tried them before
but never for this price keeps
treatments can take up to four to six
months or more to see results so it's
important to act fast as soon as you
start using it the more hair you'll save
find out why keep says more 5-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly a hundred thousand men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication listen nobody wants to go
bald very few people could do it as
Woody Allen says you know I don't know
if I'll be the balding virile type you
know there is a certain rogue in people
like that can
a lot of people can't most people can't
so the reality is you need some hair up
top you know so the reality is you know
I know a friend that uses this this is
how we got in touch with the company it
really works they are paranoid about
losing their hair I'm not gonna say who
it is a comedian so the reality is
they're very happy with this product I
do not have that problem yet I mean my
hair is very long its luscious its
luxurious but lots of people don't have
that situation you know what I mean um
you know so my friend loves this stuff
and we you know we're happy to bring
this company out there for people that
do have that issue and if you do have
that issue you got to do something about
it because nobody wants a patchy head of
hair so if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to keeps calm
slash Tim Dylan that is ke EPS calm /
Tim Dylan okay
ke EPS calm / Tim Dylan if you are
paranoid if you see a receding hairline
if you think it's gonna get ugly up
there if you're you know losing
confidence especially if you're a guy in
your 30s you know I'm 35 and this starts
to become a real problem for people in
in their late 20s so if you want to
avoid this you can save your own hair
it's not a toupee
it's not you know surgery any type of
surgery this is saving your own hair if
you do it okay there's only two FDA
approved hair loss products out there
and this is the generic version of that
it is the cheapest way to do this so you
can save hair and money it is true I
mean this is something where even if you
don't think you need it you need it
that's the reality if you don't know you
need it you need it cuz one day you're
gonna wake up and all of your hair is
gonna fall out and you're gonna get up
and it's all gonna be over I mean it's
all gonna be over all of it whatever the
it was that you enjoyed done okay so the
reality is you better start taking
precautions
now with K EEP s.com /cam Dillon
I mean I'm talking to out there I'm
talking to the people in the audience
they're doing the best I can with what
they have you're doing the best they can
with what you have there's a lotta out
there doing the best you can with what
you have give yourselves a little bit
more
that's the message okay give yourselves
a little bit more cuz you're doing the
best you can but why don't give yourself
something to work with
okay don't walk in with a patchy head of
hair and bad skin and this and that to
do something get yourself in a tip-top
shape okay phenomenal
alright everybody he's a longtime
listener first-time caller he is not
dead so many people messaged me is ray
dead he hasn't put out his podcast we've
not heard from him on social media what
say you sir I've gone over some
existential depression I'm feeling
better people better people like you do
not get to have existential crises I
look I was playing that before you
called me and thank you for calming
having me on the show I was planning on
you know restarting the podcast this
weekend
look my podcast is I don't wanna like
you know liking myself toward Andy
Kaufman or a UH or Lenny Bruce but you
know I'm a mercurial figure in the world
and that's why you know that that's my
value I'm not the guy I'm not the
bread-and-butter guy I'm the guy I'm the
spicy add in crying out to go back
underground
you're the spice that gets added to the
bread and butter where people go wait a
minute what's going on
ah no I told people that I said the
great thing about race you couldn't get
what you get when you get it it look I
my friend am I try me you know uh a
terrorist about it but from a
egotistical but you know it's uh if
there's
genius to me it comes in you know I'm
not gonna force it I'm not gonna give
you I'm a Ryan Seacrest
all right the promise will make me him
now and it is awkward for many people
because many fans you you share a
considerable fan base with Ryan Seacrest
people that would be into what he's
doing you are a close second look and
but Ryan doesn't he does I'm out here
can tell them before it you know how
great would it be if you had a meeting
like a manager an agent right secret
says what is that I'm not gonna condemn
him for it but I'm offering something
similar that I think a lot of people
will respond positively to if you know
economics I'm a substitution clinical
term I know you know is but it
I remember being economics class in high
school and they told me that Pepsi
wasn't a substitution for Coke but
mustard was a substitution for ketchup
which I understand I still think it's
[ __ ] there's the kind of thing they
teach you in high school instead of how
the Federal Reserve works right that's
true that's a very good point yeah I
liked it immediately we went from
substitution economics to food like
that's the only way you could teach
Americans anything like peanut butter is
not a substitution for jelly listen up
listen up you fat [ __ ] baked beans
however is the substitution for Funyuns
it feels like we're right right
make sense it is a Memorial Day weekend
what have you done for the troops what
have you done for this country what have
you done to commemorate to sack the
brave men and women who've sacrificed
their lives so that we can see it here
today many American ones nothing with
the Americans no sorry look I respect
bravery where I see it bravery you know
you don't get to be us and be brave
you're gonna grieve about you know
bombing a village when you're in some
kind of you know like hamster wheel
plane can't be hurt I think it's almost
more impressed
that were not brave we're like running
the world and we're kind of chicken [ __ ]
right that's hot we're terrified if
everything in this country and the idea
that we've sold ourselves as like brave
and it's kind of even better what's
interesting though is some respect to
the troops because it's a weird it's not
like could we grow up thinking that you
know any we're told us that like this
weird sheltered MIT that's still weird
that like basically they would not let a
single American die even if it meant
killing a hundred enemy right like
that's kind of the model like Black Hawk
Down but nah we don't care we'll get
their body back when reality they'll let
the troops you know it's more about like
you know Mitch McConnell being safe and
vanaya
we're not ever criticizing the troops
there you are sometimes and I do
sometimes too but I say about the troops
I will suck many of the troops dicks
depending on as long as they're good in
good shape yeah but we we're always
criticizing the government that sends
the troops out to do the things subset
of troops much like cops not all cops
but they join because they want to do
certain things very true I mean
sometimes you get in the game cuz you
want to play right right it's just you
know and it's look I made even
condemning that I get it I get why
hurting people could be fun from a
certain point of view yes you know but
yeah we just can't allow it in civilized
society sometimes do it over there be a
hero and good right there don't hurt him
Oh in your own town am I too old to join
up at this point I think I might be um I
don't know if it's age but it's
literally everything else right about
you and me to offer them I have a lot to
offer militarily I mean I'm all anti-war
but they gave me the keys I'll [ __ ]
drop some bombs give me some power
I'll [ __ ] you know I'll make up for
yeah I'm like [ __ ] what's this
I'm like uh mrs. Kissinger I wish we
were in Long Island and we could go to
like the Blue Angels fly over at Jones
Beach you know from jobs they had the
young I mean my family go away until
this weekend so they get pictures with
them like 40 year old men we will go to
see the Blue Angels this weekend they
fly over and they make us proud well are
those guys like current Air Force guys
or like drunk like you know the kind of
like the the ex gunslinger is like going
around Buffalo Bill I mean these are
guys you like did the My Lai massacre
you know these are like these are people
who've done the worst things they're
probably the biggest war criminals we
have we just put them in blue planes and
they do tricks yeah I mean these are
people have probably - blood on their
hands this have hundreds of thousands of
millions and you imagine in Long Island
that's what they say like they point up
to the sky to go you see that plane the
guy in that plane killed 80,000 people
he's the first guy to drop Agent Orange
he killed 80,000 people 5,000 them were
our own troops who made the sacrifice
because we were testing out drugs on
them they came is spelled a foley and
did you ever do anything for Memorial
Day is Memorial Day something people
celebrate I can't even remember yeah at
least have like um I see I could get
blurred together because my Uncle Mike
would have a barbeque on Memorial and
Veterans Day
so start then to summer be and he had a
nice like a half acre property in
Commack and uh let me was he a veteran I
think he was better in Korea he was a
medic but he got you know stabbed in the
arm okay yeah should he's had to over
lizard like a lizard on his arm got
stabbed there yeah Purple Heart didn't
ever get intense when he had a barbecue
you ever throw a few back and it get a
little weird
oh well he threw a few back he was
definitely
the drunker side of an alcoholic yeah
but you know drunk yeah well he was
never he got he used to like Tabasco he
was he loved spice he loves spicy food
you love Tabasco I remember my grandma
complaining once because he like almost
died choking on Tabasco sauce of
Thanksgiving and it would make scenes in
that way but he wasn't yeah he wasn't a
racist I think it probably was but how
do you choke on a sauce well I think
it's just going into convulsions
you know just closing up your throat
maybe I'm not sure but he would just
dose it keep going with it you know just
just the whole bottle on the turkey hit
all right P Mike you know all right Pete
Uncle Mike he's a good man
yeah he's a good man there's always like
a time usually if you're at like a
barbecue what's a guy who served
especially that age group
we're like he gets drunk and then in the
middle you just he ever say so much
better man you know like some like scent
of a woman like outburst well he would
never do that so now I'm an adult man
I'm looking back forever and thought
about in a while but keep so nice he was
so like oh he's not white for the party
and no he's just good-hearted so he
probably did some bad [ __ ] yeah he
probably was you know if I had he
probably got his fill of being
aggressive yeah I don't remember I
remember like like we would me and my
father would go like when they had these
Blue Angel flyovers like we would hang
out with his friend who owned a steak
house and and and a few of his friends
and we would all like drive to Jones
Beach that strip of land in Long Island
and then watched the Blue Angels and
then just drive back to you know
someone's house and sit in the backyard
and you know and I don't remember if
that was a Memorial Day or fourth of
July it all kind of blurs I mean if you
think about fourth of July see I can't
be always the state put on 4th of July
but I guess people move around I guess
people go
the beach and stuff but uh morphos July
feels more like you know you wouldn't
want to leave like jump houses back and
forth but many people do I guess we
always has our house what I love about
Long Island is there's an unending well
just a deep well of patriotism yeah well
after 9/11 we went driving around just
honking our horns just waving flags you
know it was fun I mean like it was
anyway but I'm not saying it was worth
it but it was nice yeah well we bang
there are people that bang pots and pans
now for nurses that can't hear them yeah
I mean I live in Brooklyn I'm here
apparently they cheer every day I've
ever heard this apartment in two and a
half three months you went out and you
started banging a pot or a pan you would
be immediately arrested
the cops are back get in the [ __ ] car
you bet I'm doing this for the heroes
you better get the [ __ ] in this car he's
talking about his nurse I think he's
four yeah he's trying to kill this nurse
with a pot he's got a wife shooting
three times he's got a weapon I'm trying
to do this from the [ __ ] hero
I mean look what's going I mean I think
we're at a third of what we were the
peak in New York I went through wherever
I was a month and a half ago I kind of
know about as much I kind of stopped
listening to anything I know a few and
they're starting to try to reopen this
[ __ ] so we're probably gonna go right
back into a pandemic look at the split
yeah I just don't know if the people or
the system of government I don't know
what is worth saving here Oh a great
point cuz here's the thing we have
handled this so poorly on that we have
to do this we have to ruin the economy
know if any of us were reasonable I mean
if Trump and his cronies had gotten
tests but also if people had just like
stayed home on st. Patty's Day it would
have saved lives right no drink green
beer and eggs or whatever they do yeah
don't want to live I mean that's really
the crux of it people in this country
have a death wish
and they're allowed to have it and they
should have it what we have to live for
right right look it's one thing people
have this image of Rome where like the
the Huns and Attila was on the footsteps
of Rome and it was all and like we won't
we don't mind going out like that the
blades of glory they forget that there
was hundreds of years of kind of decay
and like you know losing your grip
before that happened and that's what
we're in like there's there's no fun
being in the gradual free fall yeah
there was hundreds of years in Rome of
payday loans and bad baby and [ __ ]
whatever verges the dumbing down of
everybody and apes giving people [ __ ]
epilepsy or whatever yeah just two plays
being bad you know whatever Roman
version of theater they had people be
like these suck now these used to be
funny I mean the tiger eating a [ __ ]
I don't know like a [ __ ] no more
crispy they stopped eating the critter
that's the problem for a while they were
eating the Christians and people like
that then they they start becoming
Christian and they know who wants this
yeah we want [ __ ] Rome was founded on
like let's kill each other let's get
some blood in their hands and they come
up with Jesus was like what no we got
rid of him Jesus or as we call them
today Andrew Cuomo right oh maybe don't
kill you a Grimm like the idea that like
I knew that I was like having a cosmic
break or like a split with humanity
well like people I know and respect it
thank God not uke's for usually on the
same page but they like no one liked
well like you got a watch Andrew Cuomo
speech it is the most inspirational
thing you'll ever see and I watched it
I'm like what the [ __ ] are these people
talking about the bar is so low now look
if you go back and watch Jack Kennedy
John F Kennedy President Kennedy the
speeches were well written you know
Charles
with whatever whoever he had writing for
him there were good speeches it was
barely inspiring Obama was pretty good
like though and they blow away this
[ __ ] meatball peddler all right but
you also can't bring people because like
they're just impressed that someone
isn't literally calling someone you know
the n-word right behind the scenes watch
the governor right now he has not said
the n-word this is a leader this is
somebody we can all get behind he says
it behind closed doors with his family I
bet you he says a plenty during a sweet
16 of Knights of Columbus right when
he's goosing 17 year old girls dirty
Andrew Cuomo
let's start a rumor that Andrew Cuomo is
a pedophile he's in a heap of file or
whatever they call let's let's start
something called meatball gate about the
Cuomo brothers and say that they're both
running a human trafficking ring they
hold a meat ball between each other's
[ __ ] when the girl has to come and eat
the meatball you have no idea what the
Cuomo boys do there's something called
sausage and peppers okay
you know it's sausage and peppers is
when they take their dicks and they're
both [ __ ] a girl and then they start
cutting her skin up with knives so it's
like onions and peppers that's sick the
Cuomo boys yeah I mean I also hear his
brother is he still like like dying in a
basement somewhere in like Westchester
whole thing was fake right he claimed to
have coronavirus and he claimed to cure
it by stretching he was like I do these
breathing exercises it's not just
breathe you have to really breathe he
silver halide yeah and then like two
days later he's like dancing in his
house and every I mean it's like hey
listen I don't I need to see the test
result III I smell a rat not sure look
eaters Alba probably didn't have it Tom
didn't like you know I think it's a real
thing I do think some of these
celebrities you know they just [ __ ]
said hey yeah we would need to calm
people down once you go do a little
Skype Channel thing do you think what do
you think Boris Johnson had it or you
think he'd just spent a few days in a
hotel that dumb [ __ ] wouldn't stop
shaking the hands of like dying patients
he's old-school British he's going to
the third world and my kissing [ __ ]
third-world people like lepers you know
the British Empire to walk around Mumbai
and just kiss kiss legless legless women
they they're thankful for Britain
they're thankful for it and I make sure
they know how lucky they are
I'll give him a big wet kiss have one
tooth in their mouth and I'll lick it
yeah he say he's an interesting
character what's your pretty friends
have David Cameron right look he went in
one of the same prep schools and
everything I didn't know that yeah he's
[ __ ] Street pretends to be this
[ __ ] like man the people kind of guy
he went out the same exact [ __ ] look
was it Wharton over there are you
telling me are you telling me that the
ruling class has split off into two
groups one that pretends to be men of
the people and one that are clearly
comfortable being not men of the people
and yet they're both rich they both
protect each other and they both
propagate the same policies large latent
I'm whoa I let me proof yet but go watch
the Blue Angels to get proud of being an
American
those guys drop bombs on people and
murdered to make killed all those people
that we're gonna kill us
all those people of Vietnam that we're
gonna come here and kill you family that
killed them all those kids was it
impressive when you saw it I mean not
really even then I think as a kid you
barely care you're a kid you don't give
a [ __ ] you just want to go smoke weed
you know you just want to get high you
don't want to give the camera to what
the [ __ ] Blue Angels are doing the
displays of patriotism in Long Island
are particularly hysterical well love is
like cuz you look Russian so why we both
watch the Americans again
and like you know still like people who
were alive during World War two from
Russia by the embrace like how brutal
are we lost 40 million people the
world's eating [ __ ] and [ __ ] you know
he eating rocks America like the height
of patriotism was like the first Gulf
War where like no one died that's
patriotism in America is which when like
absolutely no sacrifice yeah
like Black Hawk Down like I think we
lost ten guys and killed a thousand and
people found that depressing deep
depression because of that and we pulled
out like it's a it's really a real
patriotism yeah it's the greatest the
greatest Wars to go for because it's a
guy that we installed put her power
supported armed tried to take out didn't
take him out like you like Kuwait Yeah
right right tricked him into going into
Kuwait right with Operation Gladio the
[ __ ] Rumsfeld whoever give him the
nod why go ahead we basically implied
that we wouldn't care just do what you
got to do we just want the oil doing
Blue Angels fly over you to say trying
to inspire the people I mean he'll give
[ __ ] of trouble about half his military
parade or whatever but what's the Blue
Angels right he's right I just loved the
idea like remember JetBlue started doing
that low flyover over New York City for
coronavirus and everybody was like every
thought 9/11 was happening they're like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with JetBlue it's
dumb on their part but also like after
the fifth day we knew own planes aren't
gonna hit us again never did in the
first place probably he's probably CIA
like you like can you stop being such
[ __ ] cops that you're afraid my
eleven again by bursting go you just
imagine like somewhere Langley Virginia
they're doing a pitch meeting and
what about more plays ago we got a virus
it's great what we got right now is
great they don't leave their houses get
terrified they're gonna let us put chips
in their ass like we don't need any
planes it's just a disappointed CIA guy
he's got two planes like Leckie he
worked hard on this mock-up and he's
just like he just walks out of the room
he's like [ __ ] you know he's like [ __ ]
it's all the German people now that's
all they care about is the cherub people
he's trapped three Muslim guys last week
no one cares he called up Larry
Silverstein like sorry Larry's a no-go
Larry Chino ago we tried he we tried
he's like he's like I handed three
Muslim guys the anthrax last week no one
cares no one cares because of this bat
disease who came up with this you know I
mean we're just having fun folks it's an
entertaining program we don't believe
any of this we believe everything that
we're told Michael Hastings was a
[ __ ] traitor
he was I love like going overboard where
you're like you tried to back the
official narrative but then you go like
well where'd you like JFK had it coming
and I mean that a random guy killed him
JFK was a rapist and he sold out this
country and what I mean by that I mean
what do you think happens with the sub
what kind of summer are you are you
expecting to have not much
I might depending on situation uber at
the Long Island see some people if it's
like you know open but we're pretty much
staying inside I'm working from home
right now honestly the time blurs for me
it's kind of weird like it's I mean
happy what I have a balcony so something
I'm just you know in a way I'm not like
in a lightless room like I used to be I
I have a sense of time but I will be
doing I'm not gonna be barbecuing every
weekend the idea that somebody calls you
to check up on you and they're like hey
how are you doing and you're like I'm
not in a lightless room like I used to
be
I have a sense of time I have a sense of
time now it's like it's like what kind
of Game of Thrones answer is that like
the three-eyed Raven has seen the future
and the future is the Blue Angels will
fly over Long Island and fat people will
say the n-word yeah I see myself being a
little more careful than a lot of people
probably well both are not small No yeah
not particularly healthy not
particularly healthy I mean I'm trying
it's very hard it's very difficult right
so I'm not going to venture out too much
maybe do these meals where they send you
the meal like blue apron yes but they're
did that you cook they have ones where
it's like meal prep you just buy a bunch
of meals it's like nine or ten dollars a
meal and you just heat them up and eat
them that's not bad I mean was the
company we'll talk about later there's a
luncheon
none of them response from the show so
I'm not advertising any of them every
magic spoon keto cereal is it good no it
tastes like fruit loops you like fruit
loops
sure so if you eat magic spoon it's
fruit loops but it's none of the guilt
what's it gonna add this week we did
like if we you what is it me it's a meat
cereal yes not serious it's meats tried
turkey meat wow it's a dried fruit it's
tried turkey meat and they toss it in a
fruit dust fruit to us but fruits got
sugar in it but it's not fruit it's it's
it's meat that tastes like fruit so
you're eating meat with milk it's me
it's a meat it's meat milk they call it
meat milk no I'm kidding I'm joking you
but what I am Telling You is about magic
spoon dot-com / Tim Dunn what's in it
will they make it they take monk fruit
and they use it to sweeten the cereal
that's what's read part what it's like
instead of grain what is it Parmesan
cheese it's other
it's a high-fat keto paleo everything's
okay that's what it is everything's okay
I'm sure it's fine I'm just asking
because what's good about it is you can
eat it without the guilt because it's
it's fat and not sugar and fat is good
and sugar is bad right no I'm totally
I'm totally in so it's basically chicken
skin that's been fried and rolled into a
circle it is deep-fried pork products
okay it's pork rinds
it's pork rinds that have been made in
cereal it sounds like I wouldn't think
it would go well with milk but I mean I
might like go preach out on I'm kidding
magic spoon is a great cereal everybody
loves it if you're on a keto or Paleo
diet it's an easy meal replacement what
you're able to do is eat it late at
night not feel guilty if you need
something to taste sweet it's date they
use high quality sweetness like monk
fruit I understand I just don't know
what the base is I will tell you what it
is I'll tell you what it you want to
know you wiseass yeah it has your sugar
12 grams of protein 3 I'm gonna tell you
right now what it is
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb GMO free they've
got good ingredients I'm sure they're
great but are they meet I don't think
it's me okay I definitely go out and buy
it I'm just curious
well you might have to go out and buy it
you got a magic spoon calm slash Jim
Dylan and grab a variety pack and try it
today
romantic song calm slash Tim Dylan and
then you buy it right from the now gray
it is a little pricey it's $10 but what
is right what for how many boxes no it's
the fruit you get a box for 10 look
meats not cheap so I get it it's not me
but it's high protest waiting just the
cold cereals can be cheap it's like it's
flaming yard you're eating it's a
by and everybody writes a fruity ribeye
and everybody won't be cheap about it if
I can buy you a nice treat I hope they
changed their model too
just as we call it cereal don't mean it
ate steak that's the way you gotta look
at it it's a great way to phrase it
right you gotta look at it like that it
isn't cereal as much as it is a bowl of
high-protein very healthy food right
like no it reminds you of your childhood
but it's actually recently killed goat
yes and what's good about it is that
you're able to enjoy nostalgia exactly
but I never liked about cereal is that
was never butchered first yes this is
butchered and and drained of its blood
by being hung upside down right is it
kosher
we're like a dirty animal it it's it's
clean and I believe halal and kosher
okay so the day after like hanging up by
its [ __ ] foot and drink cut its neck
yeah they do every day don't the animal
doesn't know it's dying its slaughtered
and then made into cereal somewhere in a
lab the animal never knows it's gonna be
cereal I think they have a talk with it
first but they explain to it that we
have such a weight problem in this
country they're dying for the much like
those children with Boris Johnson yes
for the Empire here's what I will say
the magic spoon / Tim tail and all
kidding aside I enjoy the cereal I tell
everyone about it it's great to get
healthy there's a lot of people out
there that want to get healthy but need
to eat a sugar cereal like for a child
it's true there's a lot of people that
are deeply committed to health but can't
not eat cocoa puffs if you're the kind
of person who you know decides I'm gonna
lose a few hundred pounds but still be
fat but lose a few hundred pounds and
like has to do it eating strange husk
oat pancakes yes you might magic yes
absolutely we follow some fat people on
on Facebook who
or what they do is they're losing weight
by like substituting the most unhealthy
things but substituting like almond
flour and that and then just still
making like pancakes with whipped cream
every morning with caramel sauce but
they use like low sugar caramel and it's
like you still sad it's like it's a it's
a Crisco but with caraway seeds in it
right we should really honestly how
great would it be if we became like
serial killers who killed fat people
[Laughter]
great pitch we should pitch that show
we're so disgusted by other fat by the
way and you'll back me up on this is
anyone more hostile to fat people more
than other fat people no especially when
you start losing weight even if you lose
5 pounds you come just stood by people
who are less fat than you yes I am
telling you right now I've been fat for
a lot for a long time the hatred I have
of other fat people
there's no way thin people hate fat
people as much as I do there's no way
there's no way because thin people don't
see themselves in a fat person they
don't care but when I see a fat person
I'm like oh [ __ ] you stop wearing that
pugsley shirt take care of yourself like
me and Ray went to the pizza buffet in
Long Island and we were so all these
other fat people walking in and we're
like what a disgusting country meanwhile
we're just like [ __ ] dripping pizza
sauce into our recorder
yeah we're like what a disgusting
country the guy who helped us do that
episode is now having a baby
oh is it yeah he's having a baby his
name on here I don't want to say his
name okay yeah he also I heard them
things about his steaks
I said I'm guy right steaks you have an
episode we were gonna get into it what
hey can you [ __ ] get mad about it
well he Cleo he cooked a well-done steak
for me and I didn't I thought it was
I thought it was should have been called
out yeah but now he's having a baby so
you know it's nice
good for him is he gonna keep it they
don't know she's she's like four or five
months in they're gonna make the
decision in a few months like eight or
nine months in just go in there and get
it yeah I mean look why not wait and see
if it's gonna be a good-looking baby
maybe he's got a great dick maybe it's
[ __ ] a pretty baby you know why you
know like you know dump your dumper your
hand before you know what if he went
what it what if literally what if the
first thing he said to the doctor he
looked at the doctor because you know we
were gonna kill it but it's got a great
dick doctors like ah I report these
people did you see what do you say my
mom always tells me the I as a baby had
a great dick well when he circumcised
mean he had to use two forceps is that
true so she tells me what a great
anecdote to share with people thank you
that's you the way you should start your
college commencement speech
my mother said when I was a baby the
doctor I used to to forceps or
circumcise my death she also had friends
your prayer group I might mention this
on the old episode who would who
confided to her their church prayer
group that she was with her baby would
cry not because she wanted to you know
for her own sexual gratification but her
baby wouldn't stop crying and the only
way she could get to stop crying was the
second stick no ray we're trying to
advertise and make money here what do
you mean what do you mean that is some
woman in a prayer group said dad my mom
was part of what they called a
charismatic prayer group what this is
Morris matic prayer group it's not what
it sounds like they would get together
and they would pray very intently for
one thing to happen so like so we would
win the Iraq war or whatever I mean this
is the 80s probably just so that you
know Michael Jackson
would make you know another great album
with anything you know Grenada would
what the operation Grenada would go well
whatever so you know they would get
together and then I guess during the
coffee break or whatever this woman can
fight it to my mother that her baby
McNown I just couldn't stop crying and
was driving me crazy
and look you know some people go so
crazy from your baby crying they shove
it in the freezer and they kill it it's
a it's a thing it's traumatic to some
mothers
so but in this case she didn't feel it
many people how many people are putting
the baby in a freezer because nice
according to like you know Sally Jessy
Raphael at least five okay I remember
seeing these people on the panel it
happens I'm not saying it's common so
I'm not saying it's common for what this
woman did but she went a different
direction
she said look I just I realized I was
just trying different things I put his
penis in my mouth and stopped crying so
don't do that
did your mother report her no I think
she told I mean I would have my mom
didn't think it was you know she wasn't
she wasn't supportive of it she probably
should report her but I don't think that
his woman was getting off on it but it's
not good it's definitely rape how do I
talk about Ridge wallet now situation so
keep his card in your Ridge wallet I
mean the horrors of the world what
people could find to each other in
prayer groups are right I mean these are
all the churches we need to reopen by
the way these are all the churches that
need their essential we need to reopen
them make sure yeah I can
don't don't social distance from his
dick I guess Jesus Raymond Cobb
I mean Anwar we're gonna we're gonna let
you go you are into them you're an
amazing character thank you so much tell
the people Harry tell the people word if
I just can't I
know that we can legally top that story
on the air so you can find me at rate
comp on Twitter and Instagram the
podcast is come weekend and the patreon
is ramping up of making up for lost time
so you don't worry about that we're
gonna be we have we have a week of come
per something like yeah it's gonna be a
cavalcade of ten did you hear about this
new show where there's a [ __ ] in the UK
it's called labor of love and there's
going to be like a bunch of people
living in a house competing to
impregnate a 41 year old woman I mean
can I get an IV but but are the chances
of the baby being born with something
wrong when you're 41 so much hot I mean
what's one more [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
up baby
who cares I mean you know what the
show's gonna make millions of dollars
you can tell me that like so we'll take
care of the baby like they probably have
accountants and lawyers like alright so
we have to like pay for scholarship for
this kid to go to like second grade and
then that's it whatever we have a second
grade scholarship it's gonna get a lot
worse than that that's all I'm saying
if you're offended by that just know
it's gonna get a lot worse than that
rate comp I hope people go and find you
did you watch the video today the karana
ball oh you did no I didn't tell me that
very well you should go check it out
it's a good it's a good video people are
enjoying it I'm sure it's great
hi DRAM thank you thank you sir